[Applaus]
[Musik]
er ist einer der erfolgreichsten Komiker
und Alleinunterhalter der Schweiz Peach
Weber
[Musik]
zu den auftreten fährt Peach fast immer
allein auch heute am Abend wird ihn in
luzernischen Ebikon sein Publikum
erwarten schon um zwei Uhr macht er sich
auf den Weg
jede Woche
und ich mir saubere Seile
war ich das auf jeden Tag lang aus der
Musik alles klappen geht und so und wenn
es der Körper
[Musik]
in fast 50 Jahren hatte Aargauer eine
geballte Ladung Humor abgeliefert
jetzt Fernsehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kann nur wer nicht wirklich blöd ist
seit Jeans the Peach
ja ich glaube das stimmt
und darum
[Musik]
nimmst du zum Grillen Kerosin fliegt ein
Steak in Engadin
nein
aber natürlich ist dann hier irgendwie
bösartig meint sondern einfach solche
betroffen fühlt weil es geht eigentlich
das Thema was ich nicht irgendetwas
eigentlich nur noch zwei drei Tage
[Musik]
bin ich irgendwie schon wenn es von der
richtigen
indirekte Vegetarier oder weil alle Mini
Lebensmittel sind vergeht
[Applaus]
Arier lustig machen also ich meine
eigentliche Stelle oder Eicheln wenn
mehr dirle nicht essen warum sitzt er
das Fleisch
sein Haus in Hecklingen nennt der seine
kreative Oase
es wächst
geil
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine erotische Komponente
bitte komm mit der Hut Weg das erinnert
mich ein bisschen
am Schluss probiert und sein Alter sieht
so gruselige steile mehr Pizza wenn sie
wieder mal nicht
am Kochen bin fertig
und da werden wir das Date gemacht hat
die der Wirbel die ganze Woche ausgelöst
sowieso fasziniert das ist trotzdem
Erfolg so bescheiden bin
einfach sogar
die wichtigsten Stationen also das
Wichtigste aus dem Lebenslauf ich bin
1952 im Alter von 9 Monate geboren
ja schon gefragt ne das geht echt das
denn 1958 bin ich Kindergarten
1964 bin ich die zweite Klasse
Peach wächst aus Peter Mario Weber in
Wohlen auf zusammen mit seiner Schwester
Carla und seinem Bruder Marcel in Trio
der Geschwister ist Peter der älteste
weil es in seiner Schulklasse mehrere
Peter gibt nennt er sich Peach tiere
spielen in der Familie eine große Rolle
der Vater ist freischaffende Architekt
und hat ein spezielles Hobby er züchtet
exotische Vögel die er auch öffentlich
ausstellt
Vogelfreund Caesar Weber ist mit Recht
stolz auf die Ausstellung
durchstelligt Tiere und Blumen in wollen
zeichnet sich aus dort dass sie sehr
viel Seltenheit
wer glaubhaft machen kann dass er all
die dir schon mal gesehen hat ist euch
Gast jeden
[Musik]
Wahnsinn einfach
und hat sich selber immer Allianz
[Musik]
jetzt gerade vor
gerade über den Kreisel ja
auf dem Weg zum Auftritt gönnt er sich
fast immer einen Zwischenstopp
[Musik]
ich habe das immer
allein gemacht und es ist mir eine
Durchfall oder dass ich so lange mache
als ich zum Beispiel
braucht sich
Musiker
bis positiv ist eine Treppen aber da ist
oder ununterbrochen ist
könnte singen oder Gitarre spielen
und ich möchte gern die Tradition
weiterführen
ich kann nicht gewusst dass ich so gerne
spielen
Dirigent für deine Musik etwas gut will
ausprobiert
Musik ich war es in der nicht überlebnis
gehabt
und doch schaffen es seine musikalischen
Späße immer wieder in die Schweizer
Single Hitparade
[Musik]
i love you everybody
Sideboard
[Musik]
now I make a solo on my Pixies
[Applaus]
musikalisch versucht sich Peach zuerst
als Schlagzeuger ich bin der einzigste
[Musik]
und ich hatte aber sehr glücklich
gesehen
ja so gut
ins grundbasant sein aber Frau freut
euch
und das eigentlich mehr an der
pankreilie erfunden und das Ziel sehr
[Musik]
aus Lehrer ist natürlich realco
zuerstammt und da hätte ich auch ein Ja
[Musik]
nach dem Seminar unterrichtet Peach acht
Jahre lang als Oberstufenlehrer in
Wohlen
mit
Druck und da hat mir wirklich am leere
fasziniert und ich finde das eine von
der schönsten Prüfung
[Musik]
ich bin es Aargauer bierblick und Hannes
ganz großes Problem
die andere Schweiz
aber ich glaube dir können nicht Drums
ich bin ein Aargauer und bin stolz
darauf
das weiß doch schon jedes Kind das mir
Aargau einfach erklärt
wollen
[Musik]
es gibt viel Verkehr Millionen
Futuristen
in seinen jungen Jahren fast Peach den
entschloss sich politisch zu engagieren
auslöser sind ungelöste verkehrs- und
andere Probleme in Wohlen und dass sich
in der örtlichen Politik kaum etwas
bewegt
wenigstens probiert also ich hatte nur
eine
Kolleg fragt oder mekon
[Musik]
mit Joe Wanne Ludin den er aus der
Schulzeit kennt gründete er eine Partei
die in der Lokalpolitik mitreden will
[Musik]
und das ist der Ort also vor allem auch
hinter mir das Gebäude wo der Peach
Weber und ich quasi Partei gründet hat
nur ist das anders
[Musik]
wird oiselit die Partei wächst und hält
den konservativen Wohlener Einwohnerrat
auf Trapp
politisch mitmachen ist eigentlich
entstanden
ist eine Baumkrone
[Musik]
Politiker nicht aufgegriffen wurde sind
Umsätze also
Verkehrsberuhigung Abbruch von Häusern
verhindern sogar antikark kW
kränkkraftwerk und so weiter so bewegen
wir vertraut
Atomkraft ist ein Thema das Peach nie
losgelassen hat
immer falsch gefunden
Atom dein Freund oder also
unendlich Energie
ich beteile von der Generation wo wo das
verursacht hat wenn man
billige Strom und
jetzt alle Probleme sind gelöst oder
seid noch keine Erlösung gefunden
[Musik]
bereits in den 70er Jahren haben sich
Peach und seine Kollegen aktiv mit der
Problematik der Atomkraftwerke
auseinandergesetzt und einen Kurzfilm
gedreht
die Demonstrationen im nahegelegenen
akw-gösgen und auf dem Gelände des
geplanten AKW Kaiseraugst haben damals
die ganze Schweiz bewegt
wir brauchen Sie darauf aufmerksam dass
der Zutritt zum Kraftwerk Polizei
[Applaus]
von wenigen Wochen
und wasserlaufspritze
[Applaus]
und ich werde jetzt stolz wenn ich sage
Ihnen
[Applaus]
und
zwar
und dann
in der Mitte
[Musik]
wenn der Frau sucht vor allem ventini
Frau sucht wenn die Frau suchten
[Musik]
no no no schöne wulley
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ist das richtig ja das ist richtig
aus
sportliche Prominenz
die beiden heiraten und bald kommt
Tochter Nina auf die Welt
[Musik]
eine von der schönste Moment
ist ganz sicher Geburtshilfe
[Musik]
dass ich eigentlich das wichtigste Ziel
für mich
gehe dann ist es nur das Urvertrauen
wenn man dann kommt sie das Leben
[Musik]
bin ich eigentlich ein Autofahrt durch
sie so schon die 40er oder und ich habe
mir
gesagt ich muss dir Vorteile und ich als
alten Vater
weil wenn ihr 20-Jährige tochterqualität
die sichere Hufen anders im Kopf kann
und so und das passierte fehlende Vater
und ich hatte einfach seit ich machen ab
sofort am Wochenende praktisch keine
Auftritte
die Entscheidung
weil da kann man mit allem Geld und
allem weil sie nicht wahrnehmen wollen
so
nina hat dann abgeschlossenes Studium in
Linguistik der Kontakt mit ihrem Vater
ist eng geblieben obwohl sich die Eltern
getrennt haben als Nina dreijährig war
übersetze ihn und Texter
das wäre wahrscheinlich
und guten Umgang kam miteinander ich
habe das Bier nicht wahrgenommen
[Musik]
am Wochenende
natürlich auch
das hat euch immer sehr verbunden
und da hat sie sich ehrlich gemeint oder
aber es ist nicht so dass sie jetzt da
Mini CDs kostet die endlos oder so sie
hätte andere Sachen kosten über diese
Frage also es geht ja kein Freund
und das sind deine Armee ältere oder
Damen 100
Situation entstehen die Humor der mag
ich sehr er dreht damit Sachen um und
plötzlich gab es als neue
erwartet hast ich Mittagessen
eigentlich so richtige Frauentyp oder
also wenn Frauen mehr gesehen sind und
weg also vor allem weg und aber
ist wunderschön so das ist doch einfach
schön wenn man so eine Frau ein liebt
und verjährt
verständnisvoll ist und Tschüss und
liederschaftlich und da merkt man sich
in der falsche Wohnung
nein nein
[Musik]
Peach ist auch Autor von Kinderbüchern
an die Kindertage in Chur ist der
eingeladen um aus seinem Buch
zwergstolperli vorzulesen bei auftreten
wie diesen wird er von einem
langjährigen Kollegen unterstützt
ganz genau heißt sie wärmer aber es gibt
viele dumonald diese Aktie vielleicht
[Musik]
sich warm und recht viel
literische Mikrofon normal aber
[Musik]
mein Job ist einfach vor A bis Z ich
fahre zum Peach
fahren mit dem Peach aus
noch der Vorstellung
zwei Personen als Team
[Musik]
Bild und da könnt ihr natürlicher denn
ein paar Minuten
[Musik]
hallo
ja da ist nicht Hallo
[Musik]
darf ich im Wald hinter der
Wolke
stolperliam mit eurer waldklaffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber es geht
ältere Leute mit dem völlig Lockerungen
alte Frau sie wahrscheinlich
Aachen
aber Realität sieht natürlich anders
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin sehr gern auf dem Friedhof ich
finde dass es sehr friedliche Atmosphäre
und
es ist sehr philosophisch oder wenn man
den einfach weiß irgendwo landen und da
relativiert und vor allem wir grüßen die
Leute vielleicht
eine von meiner ersten
aber Mini überzeugt sich als Burg schon
massiv verändert dann Erlaubnis so nicht
wegen biete und dann
fahrauffällig und sich auf vor dem Altar
verschossen und da ist wirklich bedecken
und war das Gott und hat ein erst später
erfahren dass der da nur gemacht hat zum
sich erreichen am ehemaligen Vorgesetzte
was man muss besser machen ich glaube
Menschen in gut und ein bisschen
schlecht und je nachdem was deiner labit
kommt als ein Terminus das andere oder
darum vertraue ich darauf dass das
selber Dormagen
und zwar finde ich da ein Ort Winnenden
trainieren oder und Alternativen ist ja
denn nur sich vor der Zug werfen oder
besseren Turm bin ich sehr froh dass
mehr sitzende Jahre die Möglichkeit hat
wenn man denke Auswirkungen
[Musik]
Ankunft in Ebikon
mit über 300 Zuschauern ist die
Vorstellung ausverkauft
der Abend mitten im Hochsommer
verspricht buchstäblich heiß zu werden
auch ohne Publikum ist es im Saal schon
über 30 Grad warm für einen 70-jährigen
eine körperliche Herausforderung
zum Glück muss sich Peach nicht auch
noch um die Technik kümmern er kann sich
in Ruhe dem Aufbau seines Bühnenbilds
widmen
ich brauche nicht nur rund um mein
Haufen und es lieber Johannes
und das ist unsere
Abstand
Mini Sachen aufstellen
[Musik]
kurz vor der Schmerzgrenze und ich merke
da der Reaktion von der lütt sobald
dahlager
[Musik]
wenn die philosophische Texte eine Hilfe
geben
[Musik]
auf der Bühne ist alles bereit nach und
nach Tröpfen die zuschauereien
[Musik]
die Ruhe vor dem Sturm um sich noch
etwas Verpflegung zu besorgen
Studio aus verschiedenen
Rhythmus oder wieder mache Teile zum
Schmunzeln und dann wieder den Hammer
und dann würde ich Euch
so viel wie möglich danke
und dein happy lüden
[Musik]
könnte theoretische
so abstürzen
ist der auch konzentriert und wenn du
aber für uns
Entschuldigung du
[Musik]
interessiert dir
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aber die hat doch kein Felix
über 8000 Vorstellungen hat pitchen
seinem Leben maskomiker gemacht manchmal
mit Helfern aber meistens ganz allein
2027 ist Schluss den allerletzten
Auftritt plant er an seinem 75
geburtstag im Zürcher
hallenstadionsprogramm machen muss ist
alles Stadion es rasiert dass sie ihre
best of sie so schlecht sagt bin dass
man mich irgendwo eine stellen und da
bin ich noch keine damit ja noch
irgendwie will sie gar nicht
gedankenanstaltung
[Musik]
und bis jetzt bin ich gut gefahren mit
dem Versager es wird wahrscheinlich gut
dass
[Musik]
Eltern hat und das ist größte wo man das
älteren
wo wenn es wenn es
meines Lebens
ob der pitchen einsamer Wolf ist und der
muss ich sagen ja auf einer Art Show
wobei
wie leere von ganze Typen
sondern weiß genau wo das er liebt wo
für ihn auch gut sind
obwohl er alleine
[Musik]
[Applaus]